i like watching weak men [ __ ] bad
[ __ ]
[Music]
what's up i'm sam jay i'm jack knight
and we're about to answer the [ __ ]
internet
what would your 12-hour crime speed be
during the purge that's hard but yeah
that's stupid to steal clothes and [ __ ]
right but that's what i my mind goes to
but like that's dumb they're like going
to louie and [ __ ] like it's the purge
like shit's a rap yeah cause that's
stealing clothes is easy you just gotta
like dm them [ __ ] and say i'll wear it
on camera
and they'll send you what you need
really but like if it's like out i'm i
don't think i'm gonna murder but i do
think i'm gonna like hurt rich people
you wouldn't do one murder it would
gotta be oh no i know yeah there's
someone there i would yeah but then like
i gotta like get a plane ticket go to
seattle and we'll find out where that
[ __ ] but like if the purge is popped
off boom i'm in new york it's like i
don't really hate nobody here like that
but you will go to like rich people's
homes i mean i can't kill no poor [ __ ]
that's kind of
that's me which nfl team would win all
white players are all black players
this is dumb
is it is it college rules or nfl rules
nfl white you think all y players would
be a group of all black players with nfl
rules the greatest wide receiver of all
time is a white man i don't believe in
that sport anymore
i'm sad
but i'm saying right
we're assuming they all know they all
play nfl level football yeah right yeah
yeah so they all know the rules they're
used to playing this way i don't think
there's
enough
i understand what you're saying
we've got some outliers but i don't
think there's enough bro i hear your
math i hear your math their math is
there your math is there
if you could make any two people fight
in a no rules cage match who would you
choose
well i know that's whack now i died no
well this has already been it happened
right yeah i mean outside of those two
doing that situation right now the thing
the thing i would want is that my
beautiful dark twisted fantasy [ __ ]
versus the dude having sex with his wife
that's that's
that would that would answer the
question like that's the thing about it
like i hate when these situations happen
and then just like everybody just goes
their separate ways like no man you
brought us all in in this situation
finish the story
no season finale even if even if even if
the [ __ ] beats kanye i'm fine with that
right i just need something to happen
i was wanting to see paul rudd fight
matthew broderick
wait who who you got winning broderick
might beat that ass yeah sure nah but
but he don't have anger in him like i
feel like broderick got he's tormented
so he'll [ __ ]
he'll rip pogba's balls off does it
bother you if a girl you're dating makes
more money than you no please do
i have never been that is a weird thing
that we've like established as men to
like
need to make more money like [ __ ]
please pay for my stuff
depends on the [ __ ]
i do not want y'all making more money
than me because she could be live that's
her energy she's gonna be bad about it
she's gonna let everybody know i don't
make enough money
i got it because
i don't want that
but also also that's like a ground that
you stand on like i'm i'm fine with
being a little silly loose [ __ ] being
yelled at me
i paid for that like you did like i'll
sit in it you got me
my food was still free oh my god if you
could be homeless in any city where
would you choose san diego that's a good
one yes that's a good homeless city
i was in san diego and i was like
looking at home people be homeless and i
was like this is a better life than most
lives in new york
san diego is good damn that's tough
homeless and said i would go to like
amsterdam or something doesn't it get
cold
does it get cold i'm not sure you gotta
go not cold i'm assuming but i feel like
new zealand seems like a fun homeless
place that's what i'm saying and i also
feel like it's a place where they they
would wrap me up they'd be like yeah
they got you yeah they're not really
gonna let you be crazy out here just a
prostitute comes out with a blanket
well she lets me sleep in her little
window yeah let's get in my window yeah
she comes and gives you a bowl of
goldfish
would you rather burp the sound of a gun
or sneeze the sound of a bowling strike
burp the sound like
yeah or sneezing
the gongs the gong the gong the gong
here's why i say the gong when you
sneeze and sound like a bowling strike
that doesn't even sound like a noise
it's just kind of more confusing than
anything else but if you go like
it's like
i'll go sneeze why i was so distracting
but i feel like sneezes are distracting
period and then the sound ranges like
everybody sneezed different i've heard
some sneezes that sound like cars i've
heard some sneezes with people pure i
chew like a cartoon
i feel like the head go back like that
yeah
child so if you sleep like if they'd be
like that's just sneeze yeah you know
what i mean it wouldn't be anything
would you rather have free uh strippers
for life or free pizza for life like
what do you mean half like are they just
dancing or am i having sex with them
because i'm gonna i'm going pizza with
either one of those
yeah i always meant to say i don't i
don't know
[Applause]
we left and went to another club and
then went to another club and then it's
like stripper trauma starts coming out
yeah and there's nothing fun about
stripper trauma pizza pizza pizza never
told me about what their dad did
if you can see a sex tape with any two
movie characters who would it be lola
bunny and uh paul rust
the big nose [ __ ] ah okay okay he was
in uh looking to pull out the phone you
gotta know your whites definitely lola
bunny and anybody that's just oh god
yeah she's bad yeah yeah all right
you see what i'm saying
i like i like what i i don't know my
porn taste has like gotten older so i
was like i like watching weak men [ __ ]
bad [ __ ]
i'm like how is he doing this
yeah and he don't want to be like them
[ __ ] but they'd be just forcing it on
him and his teeth i would say him and
lord london wow he deserves that right
he deserves that yeah he would be good
too he'd be good to her would you rather
lose half your oh i don't know
would you rather lose half
your dick length or a half your dick
girth sam
which dick we talking about
[ __ ] pull out a drawer
took out a gold coin put it in some [ __ ]
over the briefcase
[ __ ] sharp [ __ ] long
well you shouldn't touch my [ __ ] car
two buttons you can only press one
instantly get a million dollars or have
a 50 50 chance you get 100 million
dollars i'm a gambler i'm gonna go 50 50
chance 100 million it's really hot i can
tell i can tell by your face that you've
lost
lives
he's itching to do it yeah he's like you
should saw his hand shaking handed with
the card
[Laughter]
all right big thanks for watching ati
anybody else who you want to see any up
and coming comics anybody who you think
deserves to be a superstar comment below
we'll go get em make sure you subscribe
to the channel right now